la probabilidad de ganar la lotería es
de 1 a 175 millones 223 mil 511 la
probabilidad de volverse multimillonario
es de 0.00 0001 cuál es más probable
esto la probabilidad de ganar la lotería
se refiere a que al comprar un boleto y
ese sea el ganador es de 1 a 175
millones 223 mil 511 y la probabilidad
de ser multimillonario se trata de que
si se elige alguna persona cualquiera
ésta es la probabilidad de que esa
persona se vuelva a multimillonario
estas dos cantidades son difíciles de
comparar así que tomemos esa cantidad
decimal y transformemos la infracción
para poder comparar la mejor vamos a
reescribir la aquí abajo quedamos que es
0.000
01 veamos en qué posición se encuentra
el 1 estas son las decenas estas son las
centenas estas son las milésimas estas
son las diez milésimas
estas son las 100 milésimas 100
milésimas y esta posición donde está el
1 es la millonésima uno entre un millón
ya tenemos la fracción que nos interesa
este es uno no no hay otro número
entonces esto es lo mismo que tener uno
entre un millón y ahora si podemos
comparar estas dos cantidades y vemos
que uno a un millón es mucho más grande
que uno a 175 millones 223 mil 511 esta
cantidad de 175 veces más grande que
ésta así que es más probable volverse
multimillonario que sacarse la lotería